well hello everyone as you all know my
name is dr. Miller and the SCP were
going to be looking at today is scp-303
object class Euclid special containment
procedures as scp-303 has not yet been
known to travel beyond the boundaries of
sight the entire area of psycho is
currently considered scp-303 s
containment area all rooms in sight are
to be altered where possible so as to
have two entrances separated by a
distance of 10 meters or line of sight
personnel are to be distributed evenly
throughout the facility with available
radio or intercom contact so that
encounters may be resolved quickly
personnel who witness scp-303 are to be
submitted for immediate psychiatric
evaluation
all SCP objects housed at site since
before June 4th 2010 are to be
transferred to site B one at a time each
SCP object will be transferred again to
site a once it can be verified that
scp-303 is not migrated from site with
it
once scp-303 either migrates to site B
or remains present at site
once all SCP is in question have been
transferred to site for a containment
procedures will be updated as
appropriate description witnesses
described as CP 303 as a nude sexless
emaciated humanoid figure with reddish
brown skin instead of normal facial
features its head is dominated by an
extremely large mouth which bears a set
of oversized human teeth it continually
vocalizes a wheezing noise loud enough
to be heard from the other side of most
solid doors all individuals who have had
encounters with the CP 303 are capable
of describing it in full including
individuals who have not physically seen
any part of it
a CP 303 will periodically materialize
behind any closed door hatch or other
entryway barrier opposite a sentient
observer chosen by unknown means scp-303
will then remain behind the door for an
indeterminate amount of time any
individual attempting to open the door
or barrier experiences intense
paralyzing fear that lasts until scp-303
D materializes either on its own or to
avoid being directly seen by another
observer the source of this fear is not
clear but appears to be similar in
nature to arachnophobia and a fidya
phobia originating on a preconscious
genetic level analysis indicates that
scp-303 is not in fact purposely
inducing fear in the affected
individuals scp-303 does not allow
itself to come into direct visual
contact with any observer and has never
allowed any one individual to view more
than 10% of its form when the door or
other entryway barrier is partially or
completely transparent scp-303 will
materialize in an orientation that
leaves 10% or less of its body visible
or cause effects from fog or frost on
the transparent surface to achieve the
same effect if scp-303 is approached
from a direction in which there is not a
solid object or door breaking the line
of sight it will dematerialize before
direct visual contact is made any
electronic or complex mechanical devices
that scp-303 encounters are temporarily
disabled scp-303 has made no recorded
attempt to physically or verbally engage
any observer how is CP 303 arrived its
cycle is not known at this time
scp-303 s first recorded appearance was
on March 1st 2010 it is suspected then
scp-303 was inadvertently transferred
along with or manifested by another SCP
on site all s EPS on-site are being
re-examined a court
incident log 303 a incident 303 one
agent was showering in her private
quarters bathroom when she became aware
of the presence of scp-303 on the
opposite side of the shower curtain it
was wheezing extremely loudly startled
by the discovery she accidentally struck
the shower curtain causing it to sway
outwards the curtain partially wrapped
around the CP 303 revealing that it was
less than half a meter from the curtain
standing erect and facing the shower
agent reports spending approximately the
next three hours sobbing in the shower
quietly as not to disturb scp-303 agent
reported that the wheezing stopped very
suddenly
at which point in time she was able to
exit the shower incident 303 three
agents encountered a CP 303 inside the
site second floor break room he was
attempting to obtain coffee creamer from
the counter cabinet when he heard loud
wheezing emanating from the cabinet and
was overtaken by overwhelming fear
agents later reported that scp-303 was
huddled in the cabinet in the fetal
position
agent claimed to be certain of the
information despite failing to open the
cabinet door later when the cabinet was
examined one container of powdered
coffee creamer was missing note this is
the first recorded instance of scp-303
removing an object from a scene incident
303 six dr. who was discovered dead from
dehydration in a second-floor storage
room it is estimated that dr. spent up
to five days in the storage room before
being discovered a small four meter by
four meter decompression chamber
separated the storage room from the
adjoining hallway scp-303 occupied the
decompression chamber for the duration
of doctors isolation in the storage room
disallowing entry from either direction
and making it impossible for doctor
to leave
test log 303 a a team consisting of
doctor researcher for security personnel
and for d-class personnel were assigned
to be dispatched to any reported
incident of a CP 303's materialization
in order to immediately perform on-site
testing these logs take place at the
door to room from the first floor
hallway scp-303 was reported to be
within room test 303 one one male
d-class personnel D 303 one was ordered
to open the door and threaten it would
be transferred to SC people duty for
non-compliance he refused citing extreme
fear test three oh three two one male
d-class personnel D 303 one was ordered
to open the door and threatened that he
would be terminated on the spot for
non-compliance he refused claiming that
if he were to do so than scp-303 with he
was terminated on the spot test 303
three one female d-class personnel D 303
two that had witnessed the termination
of D 303 one was ordered to open the
door and threatened that she would be
terminated on the spot for
non-compliance she refused claiming that
if she opened the door that scp-303 with
researcher was visibly shaken by this
claim D 303 2 was not terminated test
303 for one female d-class personnel D
303 2 was ordered to open the door
one male d-class personnel D 303 3 was
given one combat knife by security
personnel in order to
until d3 o32 opened the door after two
hours of d3 o32 died from blood loss
d3 o32 made no attempt to open the door
addendum may 1st 2010 scp-303 appears to
have claimed the second-floor storage
room as its own it has so far disallowed
any personnel entry to the room since
April 5th 2010 it leaves periodically to
acquire foundation property which is
then moved to the second floor storage
room to date the following list
describes all non classified items taken
by scp-303 one cryotube 3 sets of
standards foundation surgical equipment
2d class research cadavers one
gasoline-powered generator a variety of
chemicals including large quantities of
tryptophan phenylalanine and terracing
among others and one container of
powdered coffee creamer in addition to
this a number of classified materials
have been obtained by a CP 303 staff are
still attempting to determine what
specific purposes scp-303 may have for
these materials
[Music]
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Pichette Pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Wookiee Jax Merrick
Caleb Bowen slump god John Oh Porter
captain Gorge Tiber ball Cody tench
cheese whip dips Magee on dr. mortis
thank you so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos found some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]